get it yeah I did
you like thumb down but up dude verse
oh yeah you're falling or you're being
lowered into the mold you know now why I
cry what's going on reject nation greg
alba here and John Humphrey here
Terminator news oh I did oh god I can
barely keep my eyes open out of
excitement right yeah yeah yeah BS you
guys man I'll be su by saying the words
BS big news today is James Jimmy Cameron
Jimmy's sake Jimmy see who apparently
the original team excluding Kyle Reese
is getting back together or terminator
you GT poor Michael being Edward Furlong
and Michael being achieved and Linda
Hamilton will be returning in the new
Terminator movie yeah and there's a
variety of quotes from variety this is
supposed to be a standalone film that is
a direct sequel to Terminator 2 i love
these movies that do sequels that ignore
the other installments but I feel like
James Cameron can get away with that
Navy Terminator 1 and 2 were decently
close together for you know for when
there's a gap between 3 4 & 5 as 3 came
out way later after t 2 3 4 & 5
I I think you can ignore that because I
feel like we want to ignore that it's I
feel like everybody can do that
Linda Hamilton returning I find this
fascinating because not long ago on
screen junkies their movie fight segment
there was someone who was talking about
who should have their own TV show action
role and there was a person who pitched
Linda Hamilton and everyone was arguing
like there's no way that word that's
ridiculous and stuff and I actually
really liked her pitch then I'm like
looking at the
quote from James Cameron this is
meaningful as she was to gender and
action stars everywhere back then it's
going to make a huge statement to have
that season warrior that she's become
return and then he goes on to say there
are 50 year old 60 year old guys up
there killing bad guys
ladies arm sores a [ __ ] but there isn't
an example of that for women pretty
similar to what that lady was saying on
screen junkies when she was pitching
Linda Hamilton I like that idea because
when I think about older action heroes
I'm like yeah Linda Hamilton Sarah
Connor just Terminator 2 that's the only
bet she's talking to or like a Michelle
Yeoh I feel like that would be those
were cool female old action stars
Sigourney Sigourney Sigourney is another
I mean nowadays we have Charlize Theron
who's you know she's not older but she's
older than well I mean like Starla I
mean when you were like he did an action
role that was monumental and then down
the road you return become like an old
action star yeah so I can see Linda
Hamilton doing that and a part of me is
kind of excited I'm not that excited I
want to be excited cuz Terminator 2 some
days every day out of the year I will
fluctuate my answer between what's my
favorite movie at eat or in the matrix
it's as though it always fluctuates some
days it's t2 some days to the matrix and
recently we saw t2 3d
and I'm like this is just a perfect
movie this is perfect with like very
minor nitpick flaws but other than that
it's a pretty flawless film and she's
pretty grating something amazeballs in
that film so yeah that's cool the
franchise yeah yeah Lisa wait
terminators been going this is the
parachute to me this is like well every
one of these movies that's come out in
the past you know several years I've
been like okay this is the one I'm
excited yeah for now and if this doesn't
go well I don't know and so they pulled
that ripcord again I'm like if they
bring her back oh that could be cool but
god I hope that this time you have a
story that's worth telling and I feel
like James Cameron has evolved a little
more into businessman filmmaker and
lesha grand storytelling filmmaker you
know like he's become like what Peter
Jackson sort of is like in terms of he
loves to experiment with his
technology he wants to make a billion
dollars at the box hop busy now yeah
that's James Cameron now but when you
watch the film like Terminator 2 it's
very apparent it's a post to end right
here so when I hear like okay he's
getting involved he's producing he's not
writing or directing this film people
are like so jet that James can was
producing I'm like that's cool he's not
writing or directing the film Kai is the
other thing too is like okay one
standalone movie I can get on board with
the fact that they're planning a trilogy
is this kind of annoying to me
one at a time yeah like they're planning
a whole overarching story I'm like dude
term here too is epic it's epic and they
didn't need three movies to tell that
one movie Terminator itself isn't even
technically a successful trilogy like
really yeah these two movies everybody
loves and then a bunch of debatable
things after that I'm like we really
want to like you know gung-ho with a
trilogy again after we've had three
successfully were salman's having James
Cameron involved as an executive
producer gives me about the same like I
get so many things yeah really but now
that Genesis you know
yeah pretty dude I mean he's a business
man he's a business ya know this almost
reminds me of Jamie Lee Curtis and John
Carpenter with Halloween except there
I'm like alright I can kind of see what
you're getting at and this I'm like
Halloween has that wiggle or it's
Halloween they already got like a
billion installments and yeah those
horror franchise yeah this is like
you've got two pretty great movies and
you've proven three times over you've
not been able to recapture them yeah
Arnold and Linda Hamilton it's not like
it's gonna be the same chemistry
whatever Arnold role is might be I've
heard speculations a 2008 James Cameron
lets his thoughts out out loud of what
he thinks they might do with it it might
be the guy who did like there's a glee
at scene from Terminator 3 where they
this could you see like oh the t800 czar
modeled after this science yeah
I'm cheap mastizaade two-wheel candy I
was honored to be selected by CIS
in the ongoing effort to save American
lives so they have the t800 and nice he
sends something I'm like it's kind of
sounds like that
that deleted scene from Terminator 3
yeah then he might just be another t800
but at the end of the day the thing
about Arnold is he's always a different
t800 because the t800 the Terminator -
that formed chemistry with Linda
Hamilton is dead and picking up after
Terminator 2 I feel like they're forcing
storytelling I would be excited if James
Cameron came out and was like you know I
actually was thinking about it and I
felt like this would be great as opposed
to hey now they got the rights back
let's try to create a story out of this
so you know yeah and I feel like that's
happening more and more lately it's like
I like the idea of bringing Linda
Hamilton back in doing you know way
older female badass story I think that's
cool but yeah having a worthwhile
terminator Skynet's story is gonna be
the linchpin of this nothing tells me
that they have that and Terminator 2
like you said it takes it to the logical
conclusions from now what unless they
exploit that arm yeah yeah gears
something oh yeah yeah cuz he leaves the
arm in the factory where they kill the
t1000 and Arnold commits suicide
sort of you know now why you cry I find
this this this interesting this
announcement especially after a couple
weeks ago when he was kind of bashing
Wonder Woman yeah yeah you know I'll
show you yeah I'll show you guys what
strong female characters are I'll come
back and redefine feminism for you zan
he even referenced his creation of Sarah
Connor talking deal Wonder Woman like
well look at what I did compared to what
Wonder Woman was this is the one kind
that works yeah none of this feels
organic to me that's that's probably my
me yeah right in terms of its
storytelling yeah and terminate or
something room like just stop stop
already you know what I don't like
handing off batons yeah I not a fan of
that James Cameron said they're looking
for some like eighteen-year-old s female
that the the goal is like Arnold and
Linda Hamilton will anchor the
but the goal is to ultimately hand it
off I hate that whatever I don't know
one movie that successfully has done
that Indiana Jones for I know with like
diehard five and I think they've wanted
a kind of like hoping they could do that
with Jai Courtney in some way it doesn't
work it doesn't work
yeah it we're still trying to make it
work so we're just gonna keep trying so
it does and eventually it will pass in
the torch long it's like cool but what
where are you gonna take it from here
unless they pick a theme the determinate
er stories can tackle each time yeah if
they pick some definitive thing that
goes okay this is what the Terminator
franchise is now gonna be about cuz
right now like it's just sort of you
know just a sci-fi action movie like at
least the later installment I think to
make Terminator work they have to alter
the future timeline and have it be the
humans lose or so they have to try to
figure out a way where they can win
that's the only way I can see a were
struggle because every Terminator movie
humans wind and the terminators are
trying to screw up the timeline except
for salvation which is just watching the
story play how about John Connor would
way they're trying to alter the timeline
so the robots can win so I feel like
there has to be some major shift in the
timeline okay the humans definitely lose
so we need to figure out a way to to win
this war that's the only way I could see
it working because I'm sick of them
trying to prevent Judgment Day I'm sick
of the whole rehashing of Tudor
Petersons and terminator back in time
over it yeah this is another one of
those franchises where I'm like unless
you have an idea that the necessitates
this that makes this worth while and as
ya could live up to the potential like
none of the seek the only thing I've
heard positive about since Terminator 2
has been the Sarah Connor Chronicles
which you know shows that yeah I I've
never seen that show so I don't know
what the action is I don't know what the
story's about but I believe you can take
Sarah Connor forward there doesn't seem
to be anything special any special
reason to keep making terminator other
than we like watching terminators punch
you know people we have people shoot
terminate I just feel like it's gonna be
some crazy CGI FS even James Cameron's
involvement doesn't really excite no it
doesn't reassure me one bit like giving
it as a producer how creatively involved
can t be he's making him like
it's always like this is the new thing
this yeah hey if he's getting involved
with the Terminator if he's like
actively creatively involved with
terminator then I'm like well now that
gets me worried more about the avatar
because his focus is we can split it up
he's gonna have to focus on one or the
other and now I'm glad Tim Miller made a
great Deadpool film nothing of Deadpool
made me go terminus guy can make a cool
Terminator film which he could but you
know III don't know where that's gonna
come from there's nothing groundbreaking
in Deadpool in terms of storytelling or
action or whatever that makes you go
like yeah he's the guy for terminator
and again with these franchises we've
seen a bunch of times that you can't
just choose anybody I'd rather see
Darren Aronofsky's no offense to Tim
Miller or anything like that I liked
what he did with Deadpool but yeah I'm
like pick a director who like you know
bring a very strong like and proven
they've had a grip on you know the craft
at least Matt Reeves he's the guy for
everything
JJ Matt Reeves could do Thompson anyone
involve a Star Wars yeah well you guys
excited for terminators Herning
leave your comments below I if any of
you hate us for not being excited we're
just we're tool it comes out I've done
that I freaking it because it terminate
salvation was great Genesis probably the
best one Emilia Clarke give me more give
me more give me give me more give me
more well you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects dad John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram yay all right
click that notification about I'm so
excited for Terminator patreon.com slash
surreal rejects become a picture I
rejected a positivity is the key